ces derniers jours nombre d'entre nous
avons vu avec inquiétude se multiplier
sur les réseaux sociaux les tags
antisémites partout en France cela nous
rappelle avec horreur les temps de la
peur que nous croyons disparu cette peur
est ressentie aujourd'hui par nombre de
familles de confessions juives avec la
multiplication des actes antisémites
depuis le 7 octobre dernier pour l'année
2015 nous déplorions 808 actes
antisémites au cours de ces trois
dernières semaines ces 850 actes ont été
qui ont été commis en France plus de
6000 messages sur les réseaux sociaux
ont fait l'objet d'un signalement sur
Faros en réponse 430 personnes ont été
interpellé 234 enquêtes ont été ouvertes
la réponse de l'État est forte et nous
la saluons mais au-delà la réponse
pénale nous députés démocrates sommes
alarmés sur ce que cette recrudescence
de l'antisémitiste dit de notre société
car l'antisémitisme agit comme un canari
dans la mine la Rabin Delphine
Horvilleur je le rappelle la frénésie
antisémite révèle les failles de notre
nation dans l'esprit malade des
antisémites les Français de confession
juif sont et ne seront jamais que des
juifs et non des citoyens ce faisant la
passion antisémite s'attaque au
fondement même de notre nation
l'antisémitisme est une insulte à notre
histoire à nos principes républicains à
la cohésion nationale sans prendre un
juif c'est offenser la République c'est
attaquer la
France
de la même façon tout acte qui vise à
condamner l'autre à l'agresser pour ce
qu'il est pour sa religion pour son
origine est insupportable pour notre
pays madame la Première ministre face à
ce fléo quelle réponse pouvons-nous
apporter non pas en tant qu'État mais
comme nation je vous
remercie merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président la parole est à Madame la
première
ministre merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les député
monsieur le président Jean-Paul matthi
des slogans haineux sur des banderoles
des commentaires odieux sur les réseaux
sociaux des menaces des insultes et
parfois des coups l'antisémitisme a de
multiples visages tous aussi
insupportable depuis les attaques
terroristes du 7 octobre contre Israël
les manifestations de haine se sont
intensifiées plus de 850 incidents ont
eu lieu et près de 6000 signalement en
ligne ont été réalisés ces derniers
jours à saint-toin à Paris au
petitquevilly les habitants ont
découvert des T des tags antisémites sur
les murs de leur villees des étoiles de
David ou des des croix gamé comme une
évocation glaçante du passé au nom du
gouvernement je condamne avec une
fermeté absolue ces agissements
ignobles
l'antisémitisme c'est la lâcheté la
haine de l'autre et tous ceux qui se
rendent coupabl de ces actes doivent
être interpellé et
condamné la France s'est construite
depuis plus de 200 ans comme une terre
de liberté d'ouverture et de tolérance
s'en prendre à quelqu'un parce qu'il est
juif c'est s'en prendre à nos valeurs
les plus fortes c'est s'en prendre à ce
qui nous rassemble c'est s'en prendre à
la même de la République rien ne peut
être toléré justifié ou
excusé depuis le 7 octobre nous avons
redoublé d'efforts le ministre de
l'Intérieur a immédiatement passé des
consignes de vigilance au préfet et aux
forces de l'ordre la sécurisation des
lieux sensibles les écoles les lieux de
culte a été
renforcé les enquêtes avancent et la
justice est ferme vous l'avez dit
monsieur le Président matthi d'ors et
déjà plus de 430 interpellations et plus
de 230 enquêtes en cours nous ne
laisserons rien passer depuis ce 7
octobre les Juifs de France connaissent
le poids de l'angoisse alors je veux
leur dire avec mon gouvernement et je
n'en doute pas avec vous nous sommes à
vos cô
n nous le resterons rien ne justifie la
haine et la violence c'est notre c'est
le devoir de notre pays de le combattre
c'est le devoir de la République de
protéger tous les Juifs de France et
vous pouvez compter sur mon engagement
sans faille je vous
mercie je vous remercie madame la
Première
ministre